Peter Desberg, Writer/Professor/Psychologist:
Famous Greek philosopher Epictetus said "It
doesn't matter what happens to you,
only how you interpret what happened."
Film Courage: What is pitch panic?
Jeffrey Davis, Writer/Professor:
What is pitch panic? Well…
Peter: That's a word for stage fright.
Jeffrey: Okay yeah I will just…
Peter: Because it's alliterative.
Jeffrey: It is crippling, that's my definition
for it. I could talk about it and I mean this
is what part of what Peter does for a living and
not having it but treating it he helped me early
on with it I had a long time partnership
with somebody who had been an actor and
had been an improv and so when we would go in
she would do the I know it's really hard to
believe this but I was one time painfully shy and
painfully afraid of everything and I think that
it's a curse if you but luckily there and I think
this is the great part of the one of the great
parts of the book is the exercises that you know
Peter has put in here and the research that's done
and all of that really helps you do not have to
be a slave to to Stage right you really don't
there are and again sometimes it's great to have
somebody I mean it's okay to be a quiet person but
not what I was back in my youth which is scared
it's like you can be scared you can feel it and
still go forward and I you know I mean he can give
you Peter can give you you know the definition of
it but I think what people really want to know
is what does it feel like and I think it feels
crippling and I just want them to be hopeful about
it because it is something that can be dealt with
I've if I can come out of that phase of my life
and become sort of people call me a schmoozer
now I am known my friends but I'll tell you
quickly just real quickly before you get into the
technical areas of it which is really important
is that I would go to parties and be a schmoozer
and not have any fear at all and then people
would say well why do you have so much trouble
and and I couldn't tell you why but that's what
it was for me I and so the fear goes when you
teach too I think the fear on that first day
of teaching and I'm happy to have it I still
have a little bit of that anxiety oh can I
still do this and I think when you lose that
there's a difference between having
it and knowing you have it and then
knowing how to deal with it you know and you
just go forward and deal with it anyway but I
kind of like having that and Peter's taught me
how to it's one of the things we talk about in
the book is turning that feeling of anxiety into
a feeling of an anticipation that's one really
big thing that helps I think for me anyway
now go ahead when we were interviewing people
I asked people who are on the other side of the
desk how do you react to people who are nervous
and we have an interesting range of responses from
one friend of ours who has several Academy Awards
said if somebody comes into my office and they're
pitching and they are scared I want to get them
out of my office as quickly as possible they
had no place in there to send me the script
all the way to you're familiar with
slam dance the the guy who started
it lives down the street for me is a friend
of mine a lot of celebrities on Peter Street
yeah and nice block party Peter Baxter is
sweetheart of a guy and he said I love film
so if somebody comes in and they're really nervous
it's my job to calm them down as much as possible
because if they have anything to contribute I want
to find it out and so if I have to dig forward
and do some you know extra work to make them
comfortable I'm happy to do it so you have that
whole Continu yeah and of course you never know
the person you're pitching I'll tell the the cult
fox story the Colt Fox is the person I was talking
about who didn't work with Bonnie great but did
work with Bonnie Hunt she says that it was a time
when a guy came in very anxious and he was doing
too much he was this is the multitasking thing
you know she's he had a ball up in the ceiling
that reminded her of like her freshman dance or
whatever and she's like just let's put everything
she's a very kind person she's a one of the nicest
people on planet Earth I can Peter will back me
up on that she's just lovely and she said let's
just put everything away and she just kind of like
got to him on a han level and then the pitch went
very well so again it to me it goes back to being
authentic you know don't come in with a lot of
visual effects and thinking you're gonna and
that's gonna hide your anxious nervousness because
people see people most people are not nasty most
people in my experience are han beings too and
they want you to succeed I don't believe in that
old myth about Hollywood that you know people
are out there to kill you there's always going
to be a group of that but yeah it's nice to know
first of all that there aren't haves and have-nots
everybody will get nervous under the right
conditions I'm nervous breakdown oh did you notice
something I said no nothing you
don't make me nervous at all but
there are a lot of things you can
do to learn to manage it better
and so we talk a lot about how to do that and we
talk a lot about breaking it down to see what it
actually is and how at each stage of it you can
learn to control it better so so again you never
think in terms of getting rid of it as much as
managing it one of the yeah I'm sorry go ahead
it just I mean we didn't rehearse this
at all I'm sorry it's interesting that
it's a double-edged sword that you want a certain
amount of anxiety because it's motivating it makes
you practice harder take it more seriously and
you know actors have an expression when they get
on stage and feel no fear at all they refer to
phoning in their performance it's you gotta have
something and that as you get better at learning
how to manage it you also learn to redefine it
and again instead of calling it anxiety to call it
excitement and that you want a certain amount if
you watch athletes before a a competition you know
sometimes you've seen boxer being slapped across
the face football player you know they're slamming
on their their shoulders and stuff and they want
to get them up and they want the energy level
up to a certain level but it's you don't want
it to where it goes so far over that you can't
do anything and a big part of the problem is
foreign I was saying before that we're not
we're not built to multitask like can you
multitask I don't enjoy it but I can and
I notice my brain doesn't I'm gonna argue
with you right away cutting you off to
say no you can't okay I can now they're
accepting things you can multitask if one of
the tasks is learn to a level of automaticity
so in other words driving a car is a pretty
complicated Act and I'm sure that you could
drive in your car with me and have a really high
level conversation while you do it yeah but let's
say you just driven up this big hill and all of a
sudden we hit a detour sign and you have to back
down this windy mountain road your conversation
is gone you can't do that right now what a lot of
people do is they task switch very quickly so they
do one thing then they switch to another in the
back you know hey can you read and listen to some
you know really complex classical music oh yeah no
problem well you can listen for a while and you
can read for a while but if you're saying you're
doing both and I say okay you've just read this
passage and we've just heard this music describe
for me the way he used language differently than
most other Writers Do while you also explain what
he did in the music to get this feeling of Rhythm
by using a pedal point along with you know no idea
if you believe that you really can try this
experiment you can do it after we leave
take an expression I like
the phrase jewelry is shiny
and spell out each letter aloud while you
sign your signature you will not be able to
do it but if I say just on your signature or
just spell it out you can do with no trouble
if I say to you you know I can give you any
number of tasks that you will absolutely not
be able to do in simultaneity just too many
things because working memory which is the
part of your memory that actually does stuff
is very limited in terms of what it can do if I
say you know multiply 87 times 92 in your head
you could probably do it but you're maxed out
and if I say okay let's go to 3748 times
873 no it's just we hit our limits and so
there are only so many things you can
do simultaneously so one problem is
if you have let me go back a little bit
before you do anything anything in your
life you make a prediction about it first
if something as simple as I'm thirsty I'm going
to go to the fridge you've made a prediction
that there's going to be something in there
to drink you'll get there safely you've done
this so many times you don't stop each time to
do it but all of these predictions are there
when you said hey let's have Jeffrey and Peter
back you made the prediction that maybe you know
this time they'll be okay well I begged them
so they had to say yeah eventually they'll say
something else but you make a prediction about
what you're going to do when you're put in a
fear-provoking situation your fears are going
to start getting pretty negative pretty fast
if you're thinking about all the things that can
go wrong oh no here's the part I always mix up
I hope I don't do it and there's a couple
of people out there that look really bored
you're starting to hit your limit and something's
going to give so one of the things that people do
is they destroy themselves this way I did
I did that a lot yeah I don't want to brag
but I'm going to I'm an expert at palmistry and so
I do demonstrations when I talk about this stuff
by reading people's poems and so what I will do is
take somebody's hand and I'll start looking at the
lines very carefully little ridges and then I'll
say now imagine that I'm doing yours all right
you're very stubborn when you believe you're
right I think you're kind of unshakable yeah
no matter how much pressure is on you now
don't just say right think about it for a
second think of instances where it's happened
oh yeah now I go to the person next to you
you're incredibly flexible so even if you
think you're right if somebody shows you the
evidence that you're wrong you're willing
to switch and you'll believe the evidence
does that feel like you oh depends on what day
you're getting me the point is if I can show you
where you're wrong are you going to stick to that
idea oh you'll see and if I say well think about
it for a minute now the point of the demonstration
besides me bragging is when you get somebody going
down an Avenue of thought what they'll start
doing is looking for examples of that thing
so in other words if I said to you I want you
to think of things that a certain politician
you don't like has done that you don't like
you'll start coming up with item after item
after item after item but I was to say I want you
to think of things as politician you didn't like
actually did that were okay you probably do that
too but once I set you down that course you're
not going to look for non-exemplars you're going
to look for exemplars now when you're starting
to make predictions about where you can screw
up you have no trouble saying I could forget
this I could mess up that what happens if
I do this what happens if they say this
now at the same time let's say for example permit
me to go Greek on you. Famous Greek philosopher
Epictetus said it doesn't matter what happens
to you only how you interpret what happened
so now let's say you're pitching I'm the
person you're pitching I'm the important
person I don't get to feel important
very often so there's a big moment for me
and as you're watching me and
you're pitching to me you see this
what happens in your head what are you thinking
well I could think either maybe you have insomnia
and maybe you didn't get a good night's
sleep or that I'm boring what's the one
you're gonna go for that I'm boring yeah yeah
you're I'm you're pitching me and you see this
well maybe you have to call someone okay you're
good at this but basically where are you going
first you you'd rather be elsewhere and not in
front of me and so you know we teach people the
skill of learn how to come up with alternative
interpretations so when you see the yawn say
maybe it's three hours sleep but the person
the place where they go to first is going to be
and as you're thinking of what
you should be doing in your pitch
and the fact that you're boring people and what
happens if I forget this next section where I
always get tripped up and you can't multitask
guess what happens yeah one of the things that
we teach people how to deal with homelessness
in my own experience one of the things that
you know to put to tell us specific about this
is one of the things that I used to do and that I
would when we do practice pitching in class or
when I have a friend who needs to make a pitch is
if you make a mistake this is kind of like
that inside outside profession perception
that Peter was talking about if you
make a mistake and you say oh sorry
I made a mistake up I'd like to go back and do
that over that's that's you're slitting your wrist
you're doing a lot of visual the visuals
mimicry very good I learned not I got very
lucky early on and I had someone I was pitching
to say don't do that I'm sorry don't do that
and I've been very fortunate and again this is a
this is this is what I say to everybody I don't
really learn think we learn by what we do right I
think we learn by making mistakes so I tell young
people and I tell anybody who's new to pitching
prepared to make mistakes and that's where you'll
learn and keep notes keep a notebook of your
pitches and whether it's business or it's show
business or whatever and we said at the very
beginning they're in a ringling more and more
keep them you know keep a tally of where you
think it went wrong because that'll help you
and I don't want to keep pitching the book here
but we have a chat what book is that Peter,
do you have any duct tape well make it stick it's
so unkind I was on the cover there yeah they had
the duct tape right he was going to duct tape like
and I've been so quiet today well we haven't he's
shushing me now well I didn't want you physically
we have an entire chapter a long one in the book
on how to practice because people think they
don't have to practice their pitch oh that's
very foolish and you know one of the things we
say is after you think you have your pitch down
take out your iPhone and video it and do it from
start to finish don't if you screw up don't stop
and go back to the big go right through the whole
thing and you'll see where all your problems are
hmm and the parts where you're searching for the
right way to say this or the the sentence that
you trip over you need to learn those because
you give extra time you learn how to do it
and if you do it enough you start
getting the feeling of here's what
it's like being in the room where I can't
go oops let me start again I'll give you
an example of where this will be useful outside
of show business I have a student who for
three years now has he had the exact same job
at Disneyland that Steve Martin had so he would
you know he was doing he was outside Pirates
Caribbean doing magic and he is being groomed
to be an imagineer now that's half engineer and
half entertainer because he has to write scripts
and he has to help design new parks and things
like that so so he said his biggest problem is
he has a condition and I want to keep this
you know I'm going to say what it is but he
they are extremely considerate about it and
when he's pitching they tell him to slow down
slow down you you don't need to rush through
this that's another thing I think people make
mistake they go too fast and Peter's covered a
lot of this in like the pitch and the the voice
and all of those things and the eye contact
but I really think we make a mistake when
we want to get through something now how do
you expect other people to be excited about
what you're excited about if you're so
excited that you can't wait to get it done
I don't think we tell you know we're so focused
on the plot and the you know my school of thought
is forget the plot and think about the story
think about the characters and slow down and
make bring me in and if you're too anxious to
do that then work on those things I love Peter's
whole thing I wish I could take credit for it
but I love how we end the we end the book with
the practice chapters and then we take the reader
into the room and also I love I'm going to just
mention Karol Hoeffner again who is the chair of
my department [Loyola Marymount University] and a
very accomplished screenwriter and she developed
a mantra to help her with her stage fright
and it's they can't eat like whatever
else they do they can't eat my children
which is wonderful right and she said it helped
her because she tried she tried the thing of
imagining everybody naked and it didn't really
work for her and so and and she you know I just
think that says it all you know you find something
that that's what Peter taught me early on in our
relationship is I can tell you all these things
you have to find us we hope people who read the
book do is they find the things in there they
won't all work for everybody that would be crazy
they find the thing that works for them and they
usually one of the things I'm really proud of in
this book is that we didn't just give a couple
examples and it's not what we think it's about
you know there are there are books out there like
that one person telling you what you should do and
I think the great thing about the book and I had
to be convinced about this in the early stages of
it is there's lots of contrary points of view you
know not everybody agrees with everybody else and
I think that's really helpful I think that's what
you need there's no one-size-fits all well you
know piggybacking on that idea that may Jeffrey
came like a good idea I get one a year which is
that we should interview a lot of people who are
successful at pitching and get you know collect
some really good stories making these points
so it's not just us saying here's what we do
and then the part I added being a boring patent
which again is redundant as I said there's also
science behind this stuff so let's go look at
what the research says and between the two of
them it it's really nice that you know as you know
what's better you know why you wouldn't want our
ideas but well we can say for you that go ahead
and Photoshop we give a a pretty good picture of
you know the way things work and why they work
and what the research behind them is it and we
probably have like 250 references in there it's
a to bore people so if they have trouble sleeping
we had to put a warning on the book do
not carry this book you may get drowsy
it's like you'll be doing an audio version I
think we just yes we do and you know that was
a complete surprise to me I don't think it
was a surprise to Peter but then I thought
well it's McGraw-Hill that makes sense and then
also I'm talking to my friend Gary who is all
out all through the book He's a producer and
he's got Emmys that's not the every person we
were talking about he's got Emmys she's got
Academy Awards but but he was saying that
of course all of this is it makes sense all of
it makes sense it's just that the guy who did
our book actually is a guy who does all the
business books for Audible so you didn't read
you you weren't the reader we were not oh God we
wanted people to understand they also wanted an
actor and then then nine tenths out of you know
nine tenths of the time because I subscribed to
audible I do like a book a month and because I
have such a long drive you know Los Feliz to the
Marina I mean to Playa so I no I'm really happy
about that and there's a Kindle version of course
which is terrible because we
can't autograph those well.